let's bring in Chris Mannix who covers
the league for Sports Illustrated Chris
thanks for joining us what are some of
the ideas being thrown around come
playoff time with the NBA well at this
point the the conversations and and goes
without saying they're very preliminary
all based on the evolution of this
crisis is where would you play these
games I think the league and and the
owners are pretty I've resigned is the
right word but they've they've settled
on the fact that it's going to be early
to mid June at the earliest before they
can restart any type of season I mean I
think they're the talk some of the talk
has been like do we need to have a
training camp of some guy some kind guys
are gonna be probably wolf aliy out of
shape do we have to form some semblance
of a regular season to kind of get them
back into playing shape but once the
playoffs could start it a lot of it
depends on the venues and you know look
you'd ideally play in empty arenas if
you had to but sometimes those arenas
aren't available at certain dates so
they've discussed you know G league
facilities even practice facilities
really I mean you know I had one person
joke to me like you know they'll play on
empty why if TV cameras can get in there
so it's really just about finding a way
to get that television broadcast revenue
whatever means necessary do you think
there will be playoffs that there will
be a team crown champion this year in
the NBA I don't know I mean I lean
towards no well if for no other reason
damn is that I don't get you know and I
follow the news as closely as anyone
else and I keep hearing about how this
is going to get worse for it gets better
you know I read about federal reports
talking about 18 months potentially of
this being a legitimate crisis I mean I
don't I don't know how all that is
resolved in the next two two and a half
months now one of the questions I would
have I don't think I heard asked last
night would have been
do you have a drop-dead date I mean is
there is there a date that you say you
know this is it we have to scuttle the
season I mean I think I know that
they're talking about that and and
that's something that I'm curious to
know what that that date is and whatever
it is Dan I just don't know how you're
you're going to get things back on track
enough to play basketball I mean really
the the first date you have to look at
is the mid-may date when the CBC comes
out presumably with new recommendations
on size of crowds if it remains at 50 or
10 even you're not doing anything in any
sport if it gets upgraded to like 500
then maybe you have yourself a ball game
there so that's a number and that's the
announcement I'm looking for next I'm
also wondering about this I talked to a
source last night and said who told me
you know what don't rule out maybe first
round three-game series and then a
five-game series and then a seven-game
series you know as you know you progress
through the playoffs could you see a
scenario where they had you know
truncated playoffs you know it's a good
question and I asked that a couple of
different ways and it's not been
discussed but it certainly is something
that I think the people I've talked to
anyway would strongly consider just to
salvage any type of postseason I mean
they look you know it did there's only a
certain amount of time they can wait
here they're not going to play games
like into September like that's just not
going to happen so if it comes to the
point where they get to July and all of
a sudden it's kind of an all-clear to
play sports maybe you try something like
that I mean it's shortened playoffs
before they used to be best of five in
the first round for a number of years so
it's not unprecedented to shorten it a
little bit and look these are these are
unique circumstances if you want to
crown a champion and have a playoffs got
to you know do things differently just
like you did in 99 with the
lockout-shortened season it was a 2011
with the next one I mean they're
desperate times if you know if you want
to to do something if you want to get
something done you have to try some
desperate measures talking to Chris
Mannix from Sports Illustrated does it
seem like it was seven and a half days
ago that Rudy
they're tested positive it feels like a
lifetime ago I mean it was its wild I
mean I just
and look I and one thing I would say and
not to criticize the NBA but there's a
lot of like NBA being the leader and all
this I mean there's guilty as everybody
else and waiting too long I mean and I
say that as a person that wrote a column
you know the day of the Rudy Gobert
stuff it said shut it down I mean this
this was an inevitability like you know
this this virus spreading onto NBA
courts and amongst NBA players and and
there's certainly an argument you made
in hindsight that you know the league
should have started down a little bit
earlier but I think man this has
happened this is all just move so fast
from you know one player testing
positive and everything getting shut
down so now we've got what as many as
seven and and I fully expect that number
to grow in the coming days and weeks to
where we are with not being able to put
ten people into a building in this
country so it's it's if it's a wild set
of circumstances the player who will be
most disappointed that this season is is
canceled would be who LeBron James
easily
I mean he's having an look where we're
putting out our si and MVP awards and
awards this year for the year today on
si.com and you know I don't know that he
would have had the NBA MVP but he had a
great chance to win a championship and
look it you know you talk about what
feels like you know a lifetime ago with
me in the passing of the tragic passing
of Kobe Bryant you know feels like so
long ago right now and you know this
would have been you know LeBrons chance
to not only win a championship another
championship but also do it in a
storybook way for the city of Los
Angeles so they I mean the way he was
playing the way the Lakers were playing
I mean coming off wins over the Bucs and
Clippers I mean it's I think he would be
the most crushed by all this good to
visit with you Chris we appreciate your
time as always I am keeping local
businesses in business Dan because I
have waffles from the same place on the
way for the sixth consecutive day in
Boston so I'm I'm ready to go have you
ever cooked for yourself
I tried okay so Paulie knows
this like I bought one of those trigger
grills in Vermont and because Paulie had
one I had to get a bigger one and I did
I got it for the outdoor deck in Vermont
officially I have cooked one hot dog on
the triggers room and you've had it for
two years
yes yes I I was over at paulie's Vermont
estate at one point and I saw him
cooking a bunch of stuff up there and I
just said I had to have one and then I
got it and first of all it took me
awhile that as an idiot to figure how to
use it and then like when I got him like
I don't really smoke things or I don't
cook a lot of things so I tossed a hot
dog and a bun on there cooked it up and
that was about I want to say nine months
ago and I haven't done anything ever
since thank you Chris
hi dad Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated